une question importante quel rapport au
travail ben c'est à dire il ya quelque
chose qui n'existait pas durant les
trente glorieuses où pouvoir d'achat a
été beaucoup plus faibles freins nous on
est d'accord là dessus c'était qu'il y
avait quand même le plein au point avec
cette perspective de progrès social pour
tous associés aux canons points
aujourd'hui il faut savoir que en 1970 à
la fin des trente glorieuses 1 il ya
deux fois plus de pauvres aujourd'hui
dans votre sens et quand on est pauvre
ou seuil de 50% du revenu médian c'est
comme ça qu'on calcule pas aux calculs
est traditionnellement le taux de
pauvreté donc elle avait deux est pauvre
en 1910 et sert niveau de vie beaucoup
plus faible qu'aujourd'hui puisque rouen
le niveau de vie a plus que doublé le
pauvre avait pas bien nombreux venu
voilà y avait deux fois plus mais les
pauvres 70 c'était les retraités
c'étaient les retraités la figure du
pauvre 70 c'était le vieillard indigents
la porte de l'hospice parce que les
systèmes de retraite n'était pas monté à
106 car c'est jusqu'à qui les réformes
71 puis 82 l'arrivée de la gauche tout à
fait vous avez raison la loi boulin et
82 très bien aujourd'hui grâce à notre
merveilleux système de protection
sociale que d'aucuns voudraient
détricoter et bien le taux de pauvreté
au seuil de 50% chez les retraités il
est à 3% 4% l'important c'est qu'on a
fait on a réussi à faire disparaître il
a transformé le risque vieillesse en un
véritable droit au bonheur c'est pas
beau ça nous devrons d'être fiers vous
avez raison d'arrêter de sedan la
complainte pas mais vous avez raison il
ya des choses qui marchent on ouvre on
est bien par contre là où ça va pas là
où il ya de la souffrance c'est tous les
gens qui sont en âge de travailler et
leurs enfants parce que les retraités
mais aussi des raisons plus nos enfants
à charge donc tous ceux qui sont en âge
de travailler donc là c'est le poids du
chômage du sous-emploi et là vous me
dire mais il ya les allocations chômage
et les minima sociaux oui c'est vrai
qu'ils permettent de ne pas tomber plus
bas que terre d'accord enfin vous ai
bien compris ça va quand même ça ça vole
pas très haut quand même en termes de
revenus et le problème il ya un problème
de dignité en plus parce que les études
très importante de sociologues qui
montrent que quand vous donnez 100 euros
à quelqu'un qui travaille à temps
partiel par exemple quand vous donnez
100 euros des campus par exemple sous la
forme de la prime d'activité
quand vous donnez 100 euros sous forme
de salaire et bien c'est pas du tout la
même chose
100 euros de salaire ça veut dire que je
vaux plus ça veut dire que mon travail
vaut plus je vaux plus grâce à mon
travail 100 euros de prime d'activité on
a le sentiment de recevoir une aide qui
est bienvenu bien vous voyez ce que je
veux dire mais il ya quelque chose qui
est d'or qui peut être assimilé à
l'ordre de la charité
[Musique]